envie de voyager sans faire trop de
kilomètres et si pour Noël vous offriez
des places pour France
[Musique]
Miniature France Miniature c'est un parc
dédié au sitite et monuments historique
et c'est à hlencour tout en miniature
comme son nom l'indique 117 monuments
sur 5 hectares de parc le parc a été
fondé il y a 32 ans maintenant par de
passionnés l'un de maquette l'autre de
petit train qu'est-ce qu'on peut y voir
le château de Versailles bien sûr
Eveline oblige le Stade de France la
tour effelle et des sites un peu moins
connus il y a aussi de nombreuses
animations qui agrémentent votre visite
le parc France Miniature ouvre ses
portes le 30 mars prochain n'hésitez
pas